so you're a man named Gordon Boker in
the late 60s early 70s and you were
faced with a problem you love coffee but
there just wasn't any good coffee in
Seattle in fact you love coffee so much
that you would drive two and a half
hours all the way up to Vancouver Canada
just to get the good stuff from a
Canadian coffee company and one day
after stepping on a really cheap nasty
cup of coffee you decided that you had
had enough and you thought to yourself
why not bring the coffee you left from
Vancouver down to Seattle so you brought
together two of your friends and opened
up a little coffee shop tucked away in
Seattle's famous Pike Place markets the
name of this coffee shop Starbucks and
Starbucks was unlike any other coffee
shop at the time where everyone else
just stole coffee as a cheap convenience
item you marketed coffee as a luxury and
the way you positioned your actual shop
was just as clever see coffee houses
have a rich history in England the
original coffee houses were frequented
by Scholars and professors and quickly
became known as political hotbeds or
Penny universities wore for just the
price of a coffee you could have access
to the same intellectual discussions as
a university classroom on top a lot
throughout history coffee houses have
been the birthplace of societal
revolutions the London Stock Exchange
was originally created in a coffee house
Isaac Newton once dissected a dolphin at
the table of one of his favorite coffee
shops and in America plans for the
Revolutionary War started brewing in New
York coffee houses and this was the
exact type of ambiance you want to
capture in Starbucks so you position
your coffee shop as not just a place
where you get your coffee and leave but
as a place where one could sit back and
get some important work done like
writing your book for example Starbucks
successfully played on people's desire
to feel important intellectual cultured
while feeding them a very addictive drug
caffeine and the combination worked
suddenly everyone knew the name
Starbucks by the 90s the chain was
opening hundreds of new shops every
single year but as you scaled up
Starbucks you reach a pivotal Turning
Point see opening up one coffee shop is
easy use sorcerer beans from your
favorite place in Canada or whatever and
you're good opening up the next two to
five shops is also pretty easy sure
there are going to be some Growing Pains
but it's nothing impossible but scaling
up to hundreds of locations to thousands
of locations to the 35 711 stores you
have around the world today that is a
challenge all of a sudden you can't just
rely on your favorite little coffee bean
supplier in Canada anymore you need
Millions hundreds of millions even
billions of coffee beans per year to
keep the machine running all of a sudden
the difference between a few cents for
your coffee beans can mean the
difference between hundreds of millions
of dollars to your bottom line so the
question becomes where are you gonna get
this many coffee beans at the cheapest
price possible and it was at this fork
in the road that Starbucks had to make
the same decision that every other Mega
Corporation had to make on their way to
the top the decision to use cheap
profitable modern day slaves
specifically some good old-fashioned
child labor it was a startling discovery
that every Farm the team visited had
children working on them yes the
Starbucks Empire is based off of child
labor and you've gotten the public so
addicted to your products that they
don't even care
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the appalling reality of
Starbucks
[Applause]
so here's what you got to do to get your
hands on the cheapest coffee beans
possible you want to go to the poorest
countries you can find and tell the
citizens that you're going to solve all
their problems that you're going to
provide housing food clean drinking
water everything that they need and all
they have to do to pay you back is to
work off the debts do they get enough
money
today how much today would make
so that's just enough for food for that
for the whole family
sometimes it's not enough money to even
feed
and I know what you're thinking it
sounds like feudalism but trust me it is
not and boom just like that you have
free laborers that you can force to do
anything you want you can have them work
18 hour days you can pay them as little
as you please and force them to do
back-breaking labor that is so harsh
that nobody else will want to do it we
hear how our evidence shows Starbucks
and Nespresso are in Bridge of
international labor regulation
these are all unsafe conditions for
children and in those conditions
children simply shouldn't be working
because after all where are they going
to go nowhere they're indeed to
dead Seas too and once you work the
adults to the bone that is where the
kids come in tell those that they can
pay off their families debt Faster by
sending their kids to work and that any
age is welcome three generations
including six children live here they
tell us they work on farms that are
members of a Cooperative that supplies
Starbucks and espresso the great thing
about getting kids to work is that
they're much more adaptable and a lot
less likely to rise up against nasty
working conditions after all what's a
little kid gonna do to fight against a
giant company like Starbucks or Nestle
nothing but if you're gonna take this
route if you're gonna explode I mean
employ child labor then you're gonna
have to have a PR plan ready for when
the public accuses you of such horrible
crimes but fear not because we have a
solution
[Music]
thank you
the one thing you have to keep in mind
is that you cannot directly run these
child plantations yourself no you need
some plausible deniability between you
and the child servants because if you
own and operated these plantations
yourself if you were the ones whipping
these children into work the public
would eventually tear you apart you
would legitimately risk getting canceled
so don't employ the children yourself
just find a bunch of plantations that
are already using child servants and
paid them for the coffee beans they
produce sure it's not going to be as
profitable as whipping the children into
action yourself but it is well worth a
compromise think of it as insurance that
way when the public comes knocking you
can just say that you take allegations
like these extremely seriously as we
have zero tolerance for child labor
anywhere in our supply chain and that's
it and this is exactly what happened
when an investigation exposed all of
this in 2020 we reveal how young
children working in grueling conditions
are picking coffee on farms that Supply
Starbucks and Nespresso the
investigation found child workers on
every single Starbucks Coffee Farm they
visited children as young as eight years
old in some cases these kids pick all
the beans that would eventually become
your Starbucks Coffee working eight
hours a day six days a week Outside In
the Heat of the Jungle surrounded by
dangerous insects and snakes these are
all unsafe conditions for children and
in those conditions children simply
shouldn't be working and they're doing
hard manual labor we find children
struggling with the weight of the beans
they pick for their coffee
[Music]
these children are paid based on how
many beans they turn in the heavier the
bag the more money they make so most of
them spend their day struggling to carry
a hundred pound sacks of coffee beans
the next day at another farm that our
team was told Supply Starbucks and
espresso they came across a group of
children picking two girls told us they
were 12. and how much did they earn for
all the struggle around 25 cents an hour
think about that for a second it
currently cost 3.65 cents for a regular
latte at Starbucks so it would take one
of these kids almost 15 hours of hauling
bags around to earn enough money for a
single cup of coffee from the chain
almost two full days of work now that is
some good labor Arbitrage the labor is
so cheap that's preferably free but it's
not just child slaves that Starbucks is
exploiting in these four countries it's
also their water supply
[Music]
thank you
see growing coffee takes a ridiculous
amount of water every cup of coffee
produced requires 39 gallons of water
that's why a huge chunk of the global
Water Supply is being used just for
coffee production which is pretty wild
considering billions of people don't
have access to Safe Drinking Water right
now the ironic part of all this is that
many of the countries that don't have
enough water happen to be some of the
biggest coffee producers
Uganda produce over 5 million bags of
coffee in 2020 yet many communities here
still rely on swamps ponds rivers and
unprotected springs for water Ethiopian
citizens have less clean drinking water
than almost any other country on the
planet more than half of the population
doesn't have basic access to drinking
water and yet somehow it still manages
to scrape together enough water to be
the fifth biggest coffee producer in the
world while water isn't the only thing
to worry about when it comes to
producing Starbucks Coffee coffee can
only be grown in certain climates and
most of these places are slowly
disappearing thanks to mass coffee
production from companies like Starbucks
Coffee production causes water solution
soil erosion and deforestation if it's
not done properly in almost all of the
world's coffee is produced with Chief
farming methods that destroy the local
habitats and yet the masses we'll hear
about this get upset for like five
seconds and then they'll go back to
their addiction the very next morning
why because on top of getting them
hooked on caffeine and Status you've
also gotten them hooked on an equally
addictive drug sugar
[Music]
foreign
ly understood that soda is terrible for
you because of all the sugar and
artificial stuff in it that's why people
are drinking less and less of it in the
U.S but coffee coffee still has this
magical Aura around it where it's
perceived by the masses as a productive
drink it's a luxury on our form and yes
if you use it properly it can be a very
productive drink that's also an art form
and Starbucks has taken full advantage
of that aura a can of Coke has 140
calories 39 grams of sugar and 0 grams
of fats while a white chocolate mocha
from Starbucks it's got 430 calories 53
grams of sugar and an insane 18 grams of
fats while a caramel frappuccino 380
calories 54 grams of sugar and a
whopping 16 grams of fats and that's
just two examples about 98 of
Starbucks's hot flavor drinks contain
excessive levels of sugar per serving
according to tests of 131 drinks more
than a third contain more sugar than or
as much sugar as a can of Coke 20 years
ago people used to wake up with a Diet
Coke or a Diet Pepsi at around 2 clock
they'd have another and take a break
today walk in front of a Starbucks at
those same times at 8am and 2PM and tell
me how long the lines are Starbucks has
successfully replaced soda and no one
has been the wiser
today Starbucks has become very
ingrained in our society 60 million
people drink Starbucks every week they
don't just love Starbucks they need
Starbucks they need that caffeine hit
they need that sugar rush they need to
have that green status symbol in their
hands that's why Starbucks is still
opening thousands of new stores every
year and it's why they're making more
money than they ever have and for many
people getting a sugary fat-filled
dessert coffee from Starbucks as their
daily breakfast is not just okay it's
become normalized just like other
Staples of a healthy American breakfast
like bacon eggs sausage stalks of
Pancakes regular sugar that look more
like a cake than anything else but have
you ever stopped to think about just how
strange and unhealthy American breakfast
really is no other countries have such
Insanity in their breakfasts in fact
most cultures have very light breakfast
foods or they just flat out eat regular
food for breakfast as well it's only
America that eats straight up desserts
and junk food for breakfast and that's
because it's by Design see during the
Industrial Revolution as people move
from farming jobs to office jobs they
switch from eating bacon and eggs for
breakfast to a much lighter breakfast
the problem with this is I really put a
dent in the bottom line of America's
biggest bacon producer a company called
Beach Nut so what did Beechnut do they
hired a man named Edward Bernays also
known as the literal father of
propaganda and he was tasked with
creating a propaganda campaign to
convince the masses to put bacon and
eggs back on the American breakfast
table for good and judging by the
American breakfast Cuisine we have today
it worked see breakfast is a lie
breakfast is a marketing fabrication to
get us to eat more profitable breakfasts
breakfast is not the most important meal
of the day it is the most profitable and
we expose it all in a new video on our
new Channel evil food supply that you
can watch right now by clicking the card
on the screen we created this channel
because I've been getting super obsessed
with my health lately and because
controlling what the masses consume is a
great way to make sure they're always
tired and have low energy so they don't
challenge the status quo so click the
card on the screen to watch now